con nuestro primer invitado el día vamos
a hablar de la amenaza que representa
actualmente el extremismo islámico esto
tras el ataque de eeuu en afganistán que
terminó con la vida del quién era el
líder de al-qaeda estamos hablando de al
man al zawahiri quien creó esta
organización o terrorista junto con
osama bin laden a pesar de la amenaza
latente que representan estos grupos hay
algunos expertos que aseguran que al
qaeda y la figura de zawahiri ya no
tenían la misma influencia de antes y
aseguran que se desdibuja su nivel
global de amenaza saludamos entonces a
isidro sepúlveda analista internacional
especialista en geopolítica profesor de
historia contemporánea de la universidad
nacional de educación a distancia en
españa' profesor isidro gracias por
estar esta mañana de jueves con nosotros
en directo américa de francés de 4 le
pregunto digamos para un contexto cuál
es el riesgo real que representa esta
amenaza si existe en el mundo y sobre
todo también en los países occidentales
con estos grupos yihadistas extremos
hola buenos días a todos
respondiendo directamente a tu pregunta
la amenaza del terrorismo yihadista en
este momento está exactamente igual que
hace una semana quince días antes de la
muerte de al zawahiri y
el terrorismo soporte pista y actúa
siempre que puede bien de una forma
organizada bien a través de una forma
improvisada de lobos solitarios y en
este momento lo que se está en todo
occidente es europeo en eeuu se ha
subido el nivel de alerta antiterrorista
fundamentalmente porque normalmente
utilizan estos estos elementos como es
la muerte de al zawahiri y el apoyo que
de una forma voluntarista recibe de
simpatizantes a lo largo y ancho de todo
el mundo fundamentalmente como una
habilidad de solidaridad
lo que se prevé es que haya algún tipo
de acto de respuesta a esta está
a esta actuación por parte de eeuu y se
cometa como elementos como elementos de
respuesta
en cualquier parte del mundo puede ser
en eeuu puede pasar de ser en cualquier
país europeo pueden ser también en
países
inicialmente no ha bajado como un solo
los de américa latina que en principio
estarían fuera del radar de actuación de
estrabismo yihadista pero en realidad
van a golpear allá donde puedan donde
donde más fácil desea alcanzar un
objetivo
mediáticamente reseñar claro profesores
hablabas de américa latina un punto bien
importante no porque siempre vemos
digamos que estos ataques terroristas se
producen más en eeuu o incluso en europa
porque todo de américa latina está lejos
del radar desde la mirada de estos
grupos no sé si tiene que ver por por
hablando pues en el tema de geografía
los países latinoamericanos se han visto
mucho menos implicados en la lucha
antiterrorista que el países
occidentales países de la otan eeuu
países quedando occidental no han
participado de una forma tan directa
también mente en la lucha antiterrorista
en conseguir no tenían tropas en el
oriente medio no tenían tropas en irak o
en afganistán
pero esto desde luego no los los hace
inmunes a los ataques intereses
terroristas
la actuación yihadista y de hecho pues
hay grupos muy bien
identificados en algunos países de
américa latina
ya han participado ya han tenido
actuación desde hace largo tiempo en
países latinoamericanos fundamentalmente
en argentina también han participado en
en uruguay bolivia y paraguay y desde
nuevo pueden hacerlo en cualquier gran
país de américa latina si tienen un
objetivo mediáticamente
ahora estábamos hablando de estos dos
países digamos occidentales y a lo mejor
de los países de américa latina que
pudieran sufrir o que tienen digamos
células de estos grupos extremistas no
pero también hablemos de los países
donde se originan y se crean estos
grupos que también sufren de esta
violencia extremista
sí sin duda
hay algunos países de américa latina que
ya han sufrido esta violencia el primero
que lo sufrió fue ya hace décadas
argentina pero la presencia de células
un poco durmiente porque en realidad son
son bastante efectivas y se mueven mucho
en cuanto al proselitismo y en la
captación de fondos para las zonas de
enfrentamiento directo
aunque el estado islámico crisis que se
quedó reducido a una actividad
territorial
fundamentalmente siria otros grupos
terroristas como otros grupos yihadistas
como grupo canal son la propia al qaeda
han tenido células en prácticamente todo
el mundo y tienen tienen presencia
tienen simpatizantes y actividades en la
mayor parte de américa latina pero
también le quería preguntar a es cómo
operan estas organizaciones digamos o
cómo puede llegar una persona a ser
líder de esta organización y estar
digamos en él vivo principal de los
países que luchan contra el terrorismo
global
bueno fundamentalmente la mayor parte de
las células existentes se dedican a la
captación y la captación tanto de
miembros como de fondos económicos esa
es la principal labor en valorar lo
ancho de todo el mundo bien es cierto
que algunos de estos simpatizantes pasan
de reclutar para las zonas de combate
directo o la de recalcular a actuar a
sentirse a formarse ellos como como te
ven como terroristas y los servicios de
inteligencia de todo el mundo lo que
hace es fundamentalmente rastrear los
foros y las webs
de las organizaciones yihadistas para
identificar cuanto antes a estos dos
miembros hay que tener en cuenta que la
mayor parte de estas páginas
están creadas con los propios servicios
de inteligencia para servir de colador
desde el primer filtro en el acceso a
estos éstos voluntaristas simpatizantes
del indigenismo internacional y frenar
su captación directa e identificarlos y
apartarlos de la tentación de ingresar
de una forma efectiva en estas en estas
células y buena parte de estos derechos
los los que se han formulado los
terroristas tanto en francia como en
eeuu ceder hombre pestaña y también en
españa no han tenido una experiencia de
combate directo en zonas donde hay un
enfrentamiento sino que se han sido
adiestrados a distancia y han seguido
incluso
cursos de capacitación terrorista a
través de internet de una forma
indirecta utilizando manuales utilizando
los materiales algunos de los cuales
incluso han sido de una forma muy
superficial completa llenándose a través
de youtube
pero por desgracia la eficacia de estos
miembros
suele ser bastante bastante alta y a
pesar de que tengan un fracaso directo
en la
comisión de atentados siento nivel de
por desgracia causan bajas isidro
gracias además [__] [__] un camión
cambian pesado y ponerse tras
recorrer una avenida llena de peatones
es la cosa más sencilla reivindicar ese
atentado ha causado una gran conmoción y
desde luego una alta letalidad para
aquellos que son la vista